[Music]
but no huge fan of don't try this at
home messages on the front of videos but
for this one yeah don't try this at home
[Applause]
okay few new members of the crew today
we've got Jack a Jed and Dan there's not
new
dan how do you feel about this car and
hey yeah I was gonna take you in for
five stage but probably it's not worth
anything so just thought we play up yeah
there's got a nice red door yes for the
best bit I think so what's this
well it's my new invention it's a rocket
launcher yeah I mean it looks like a
drain pipe with tape on it but if you
say all right let's test this lobster
out
[Music]
yet not what Jack what's going on here
I'm sat in the car and we're gonna fire
fire work at it how do you feel better
all right I hope I'll be okay
[Music]
[Applause]
well not really short we learn from that
it's pretty that matches my red door
we've learned that that's for sure
which may be also learnt that fire words
can't blow up a car yeah why I have
noticed about these fireworks though is
that in Sidon
there's just tiny fireworks look at this
look at this this violet was filled with
mini Catherine wheels and an entire
miniature optics look yeah maybe and
then look at this one this one regular
fire lights turn off on the floor you
know you think yeah you know pretty
standard City little bit yeah miniature
fireworks play on the ground for the
ants